[Music]
well one of course I'm a mama's child my
daddy's kid irena Lake Clifton West that
West family is just so precious I was
saturated with love that's beyond
description I don't have a language the
words cannot convey the kind of love
that I received and it was inseparable
from Shiloh Baptist Church
reven will it be cooked my pastor had a
deacon boy Deacon hit my Sunday school
teacher Sarah Wray
fundamental for me my Little League
coach mr. Peters my cross-country coach
bo Mahan I mean all of these magnificent
human beings shaped me in fundamental
ways at the same time I was full of rage
I had a Robin Hood mentality that I
attended to course people and take their
money to make sure that people who had
no money had something because I
couldn't stand to see the weak used and
abused and I was wrong to be coercive in
that way but I needed to find a positive
channel for my rage beat up my teacher
and I was in third grader she was a
salute the flag why I had a great-uncle
who was lynched they wrapped his body
with the US flag he hung from the tree
in Jim Crow Texas it was in my mind at
eight years old Cyrus you salute the
flag mrs. G lovely teacher that she was
he slapped me I had to Joe Frazier
counter punch hit her the principal
jumped on me my brother his partner
jumped on the principal a riot was on
get kicked out of school no school would
take me my mother was kind enough to
have me take an IQ test I got about 160
something he said this little Negro has
some potential sent me over to another
school of crosses crossed away so I went
from the chocolate side of town to the
vanilla side of town Erewhon elementary
school had a wonderful time two white
sisters who were magnificent known as
solids Cecilia angel helped me channel
my rage and so I'm still full of rage
but now it's the righteous indignation
at injustice it's not the kind of
gangster orientation that's full of
revenge and bitterness and so forth that
had something to do with the power of
love my Christian faith which I hold on
to and tend to be faithful unto death
but itself style goes to check off goes
to
Samuel Beckett who are two of the great
laps Christians - the great agnostics
probably two of the greatest writers of
the 20th century actually check out the
Beckett can't live without them Kafka
would be the other for me another
agnostic in that sense full of love
though
Gregor Samson in the metamorphosis full
of deep loving compassion for family
especially as violently sister Greta
they mean much to me but it's the power
of love that power of Education
connecting life of the mind to struggle
for justice that's my story
[Music]